I feel what does me Pat man for my santa
cruz california what's up Pat from Santa
Cruz well imagine how cool it must be to
grow up in a place like that a place
that have crews in the name of it could
you imagine that a place that had crews
[Music]
dude I had some friends from a place
called Big Branch that was the name of
the place big branch so you know what
was happening around there boy nothing
onward I woke up this morning and uh
thought I was having a heart attack and
basically went to the emergency room and
they told me I had scoliosis man was I
ever relieved to know that I wasn't
numbing my chest because my chicken was
bad it was uh basically uh born with
scoliosis man it pinched a nerve and
made me feel like I was gonna have a
heart attack but I gotta tell you what
man you make me laugh all the time
caught you in caught hominy few months
back and dude praise the Lord feel all
right man
oh dang bro now scoliosis I'm look I'm
glad you're well and you sound if you
well enough to leave a voicemail you're
doing all right
do we had a guy when I was growing up
and in in college he would get all high
I mean and by he I mean all of us and we
would smoke at all bro we smoke whatever
that's back when you they didn't have as
much weed now they got all kinds of
different weed you know they got [ __ ]
euthanasia is a strand they got left leg
they got some [ __ ] died you know
kill your cousin is a new strand like
what is that
you know I'm trying to have a family
reunion and everybody's got two ounces
to kill you cuz this singing to him will
but this dude would get so high man he
had one of his mom
one of those stroke things she couldn't
talk or something or not talk but she'd
done so many Winston's that she blew her
throat out so she had had that little uh
you know that thing like that um she had
to put that thing up there at throat and
he got so high that he would have to use
that [ __ ] he couldn't talk so he'd get
his mom's little case you know when she
was asleep he'd get the case and he
bring that thing with them that little
safety case when we would smoke out so
we'd be blazed up man
I mean higher than the damn Chicago Fire
and this do we be like bar girls hit our
ice had my Wendy's that's the only thing
he could use was that law let's hit the
windy my part so we knew when he opened
that case up that he was baked out his
Oreos was double stuffed bra oh man I
need a ride home
he would have to use that little
electric thing bra oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] but
man if you got scoliosis how the hell
did it take you so long to recognize it
papa that's a children's disease and
everybody remembers scoliosis mine and
everybody had a different you know
remember school when you were young you
had to go to school because nobody
trusted you were just maybe gonna be
smart and like every four years at
school they would take everybody into
the cafeteria and take their shirts off
and I remember the first time I went I
was like damn there's some real German
type of [ __ ] but and they would have you
bend forward and show that little back
BZ baby that backbone you know you'd
have to freakin hit that dolphin bruh
and the lady would stand there Miss
Waskom or miss Connaughton or miss
whoever you know miss Barbara she would
stand
there and she would take a marker man
she would take a marker and just draw it
straight down your back oh he's good
this one checks out
you know he's straight he could go you
know back to learning and then they had
like a one group I guess if you had
scoliosis which I thought it sounded
good they're like oh we're gonna see who
has scoliosis I'm like oh [ __ ]
I hope I got it dude I'm sharing a
bedroom with my brother you know I'm
ready for a life change but but it
wasn't it was like your spine had that
little hiccup you know your spine got a
little wander II in the middle a [ __ ]
got a little Hansel Hansel Gretel you
know your spine kind of went missing on
itself a little you know your spine kind
of wandered off into the woods over
there by one of you you know your spine
kind of did a little detour around one
of your lungs or something now and so
they do everybody and anybody had that
little wah you know had that HOV Lane on
their backbone and couldn't you know hit
that Dolph and they draw the little
crook on her back with the marker and
put him in that special area I don't
know what happened to those kids man and
Daniel do it everybody knows Daniel bro
he I remember one time he took his shirt
off and they had his spine and him had
the damn uh it went in a damn pentagram
like well well that he ain't he couldn't
be real healthy so but you know Daniel
Manny's I'm not shocked he probably
shifted his spine into that shape by
himself because he's got he makes his
own choices man he made his own choices
but I'm glad that you I mean if you had
a childhood disease this long you I'm
glad you're getting on top of it you
might want to get also checked for them
so el coyol pox baby them chickenpox and
what else Oh getting a splinter that's
another thing kids hate but I'm glad
you're well brothers stay safe good
evening good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes your life well
you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one